Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn. It's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
August 25th,
2014 how's it going out?
Why? What's up? Um,
right off the bat I got to apologize to
the members of the band Chicago because
last week I actually credited the Doobie
brothers with that wonderful hit say
hey in the black.
Right.
So my apologies.
I've always confused those two bands.
There was always something about Chicago.
They were amazing musicians,
but there was just something fucking,
I dunno what it was depressing
about their sound to me.
And then after those, uh,
with Terry Kath years,
then it was the Peter Sitara years and
then it just kind of went all like,
you know, really high pitchy
trying to think of the site.
I just remember stay the night.
I liked that video on MTV.
Hey.
And then there was some, oh wait,
oh, how the fuck does that one go?
The hardest skin getting used to a shit.
I don't fucking remember.
I don't know why. You know, I bought
that stupid easy listening rock shit.
So all that crap is in my fucking head.
Now.
I woke up this morning and Butoh both
doable and all I hear in my head is just
fucking like, Yay by that Bob
on our door, but I've been,
and something about this boat that sank.
They were out on the lake and they would
deliver it and Oreos and then there was
a big fucking wave mark Walberg
when ended a little water.
George Clooney state in the fucking boat.
Why does every fucking song about
the c have to be in three, four time?
Yeah.
[inaudible] is that once
three, four? I don't know.
What the fuck is that shit. They just
make it. You feel like you're rocking.
You know sometimes this
c is nice and smooth.
Okay. Billy Joel and all you
are the fucking cops out there.
You have it. You never been on a boat in
the water. Look like glass. That's four,
four time. You've got to sit
there and rocking back and forth,
getting seasick and the crowd because
you're up there talking about a Goddamn
Segal is your finish off
another jack and coke
I eight,
eight 88 I heard or who I shot
got up black fucking daughter.
I
even just,
one of the reason why jaws was
so amazing was um, you know,
you had to the actor playing Quinn
and his old Sheltie dog. Right.
And even then, what did they sang? They
sang a song. Show me the way to go home.
Boom, boom. Bob Died. Anawana go
to bed. Yeah. Regular common time.
Not sure need men out there go on
shallow made away. They'll go, oh my God,
I fucking shut up with your fucking pig.
Lig. She'll get a prosthetic.
Why don't you come a shore?
Who is she captain?
Who are your rent it from
you gotta stay out of Siebel.
Oresteia like jerking off often mermaids
or you got to come ashore and try and
catch another bus.
It's okay.
God come in and you can cry it out.
You can put you on patch on my shoulder.
Um, I was just going to ask a
fucked up question. You know,
if you lose an eye when you cried,
a tear still come out of both eyes.
The tear duct isn't exactly the
eyeball is it? Hi. Do you know me?
I never took a science class
in my life or an anatomy class.
They didn't have that shit when I was,
well they had some of the science classes
and I fucking steered clear of them.
Okay.
Once you will pass junior high and you
didn't get to turn on a Bunsen burner,
you know,
that was the only fun thing.
I remember taking one class
and next thing you know,
I'm fucking doing like open heart
surgery on a dead frog. And so it's like,
I don't want to do this,
this frog and the die.
So I could hack it up.
This fucking dog dog,
this frog was having a
great God damn time, right?
Hopping around the Christmas
tree and I bought a bow, right?
Jumping around the fucking
swamp eight and flies, you know,
it's what it likes to do. That's
like Fritos for a fucking amphibian,
having a great fucking time.
And then some dude comes along.
I don't even know how they
killed the thing, you know,
they can't like fracture.
It's little fuck frog skull
because I got an a, you know,
what do you call that when you
cut open something that's dead.
A grave robber. Necrophilia Nah, that's
not it. That's not it, eh, autopsy.
Okay.
Like I'm on law and order,
I dunno.
Probably shot it with
like a poisonous dark.
Okay.
Yeah, but really look into the eyes of
a frog. It would look at the fucking,
the way it holds its mouth, you know?
It's just like that fucking dude just,
he's trying to blend in.
It's not hurting anybody.
He's not the quarterback.
He's not the burnout.
He's just filler in the class photo.
Can't you let them be.
So next thing you know,
they fucking whack came and then a hair.
I am trying to cut this thing open.
I fucked the whole thing up
and I got a d minus on it,
you know,
I should honor that frog and
at least got an ae taken out.
It's fucking lover.
Um,
anyways, uh, what have I been doing?
I had a a eight, a wonderful week.
I want to thank everybody who came out
to the odd ball tour, 15,000 strong.
I'm coming out to the, uh, to Jones beach,
whatever the fuck they call the,
that's the,
that amazing arena out there.
I'm not going to call it
by this stupid best buy,
whatever fucking name they give it.
Uh,
but I dunno man,
it was,
you know what's funny is I haven't done
one of those shows in a long time and a
long time. And uh, I always go
back to the virus tour in my head.
I always think,
I don't like doing shows at night
outside with tens of thousands of fucking
people here because they act like,
you know, they act like animals.
And um, which really wasn't
the case on the virus tour.
They just acted like animals in
the last two dates that I did.
And the second show was
imitating the first show.
So it was really just the one show.
But what it was on the virus tour was,
you knew that show was coming.
You just didn't know when.
It's like when you creep through a
fucking house and there's an ax murder,
you don't know what rummies in,
but you know he's in the house and at
some point somebody's going to try to
fucking swing an ax that you had
that was basically the virus tour.
And I'm so I think whenever I go to
do those, I kind of have like a my,
my fucking comedy
Vietnam flashback and um,
okay.
I Dunno. And I went out there and
I was, I was pleasantly surprised.
The crowd was unbelievable.
Like 15,000 people and you can take
them wherever you want it to go.
Actually brought him down at one
point, uh, brought him down, you know,
like a song for the little breakdown,
the Bob Seger part where he fucking
sings about how many years went by.
All right, 20 years.
Where did it go? 20 years.
I don't know where they go
home. Yeah, you do, Bob. You,
they went up your nose, you're out.
They having a fucking orgy. Yeah.
The decades kind of fly by when you
live in the rock style lifestyle.
Can you stop bringing us down?
You're supposed to be up there acting
like you having the time of your life
remember and everything.
Don't fucking come down to my level in
the crowd and tell me that you're also
wondering what the fuck
you're doing with your life.
You know what that says to be Bob?
There's no hope.
Anyways. Um, so I was on a,
arguably one of the best fucking
lineups I've ever been on,
at least since I did the, uh,
the virus tours back in the day.
You guys want to compare it?
You want to compare a standup lineups?
Let's start a fucking Internet lineup.
I mean,
argument here with the
lineups of both shows.
This is like arguing Superbowl teams.
Who'd you add the have to it would
you rather have the 85 beers?
The fuck is 79 sterilize
or any team with Tom Brady on it.
And I just fucking threw that out there
because so many people fucking hate him.
His cleft Chin.
Tom Brady has an ass on
his chair that he fucks us.
Get a check from Brazil.
Um,
okay.
I'm sorry. You know what's
great about three, four time.
I understand why you write it
cause anything sounds important.
I scratched my bows and
I brushed my day empty.
Their head headed a AIG ovaries.
A um,
all right, so let's, let's
compare lineups. All right.
So back in the day, all
right. That virus tour,
the Philly show as much as I can remember
of it, which was a long time ago,
which by the way, there's been more God
damn horse shit written about that show.
Some fucking guy wrote this all this
fucking bullshit about what happened that
night. Uh, when I got booed
and I actually tweeted back to him the
correct story and then he just retweets it
like they'd, nothing means
anything to anybody. No. All,
hey, sorry, I got it wrong.
This dude tried to say that
Bobby Kelly got booed before me.
Dom got booed before me and then I was
standing backstage with opie and Anthony
and I said, Dang door. That to me
like I'm fucking pop by.
I ain't had my needle spinach here.
Um, everything comes back to
the seat Popeye, the sailor man.
The fucking same
as another dude.
Fucking skinny bitch.
All right.
What's what these heroes, they don't
like hips. You don't like some fives.
They're little thoroughbred prints
and down the fucking road. Um,
okay.
Yeah, that didn't happen. Bobby
had a great set that night. Dom,
they booed for like 30 seconds and he
just, he told him to shut up and he goes,
what?
Why would you think I would ever leave?
And I was sitting backstage going,
I don't want to fucking do this.
Nervous as hell.
And then I went out there and I opened
with a bad cell phone joke and then they
started bullying me. And then what
happened? That's what happened.
And then Jim Norton went out after me and
never addressed it and fucking killed.
That is what happened. That is what
happened. The first guy got booed.
It's seven o'clock and then everybody
else had good sets and then I got booed
like three hours later. All
right. That's what happened.
That is what happened. Okay. For the
final fucking time, that is what happened,
right?
He can scavenge no more or
no, it was realized backstage. Oh, I want
to do this, man. I didn't need to be here.
I was like, that dude and platoon, I
got a bad feeling about this one man.
Um, so there you go. All right,
so the lineup that night,
I will not name the other person who got
booed because I'm a fucking class act
over here with my cute little button nose.
Um,
it was,
let me see if I can remember Tracy Morgan.
Okay.
Bob Saget.
Ralphie May, Bobby Kelly, dom Irrera,
Patrice O'Neil,
myself,
Jim Norton.
That's who I remember was on that show.
What a fucking lineup that is. Huh?
Patrice? The greatest comic of,
uh, you know, my generation
as far as I'm concerned.
I mean that, that's just, that's
fucking murderers row right there.
And I came out like Neil O'Donnell.
Oh Shit. Alright. And then last week,
last weekend I went on a show and we had,
uh, let's see here. Sarah
Silverman, Hannibal Burress,
Louis C, k, David.
Tell Myself Jeff Ross,
uh,
Chris Hardwick
and uh,
who else was on that show?
Some yoga comic and I fucked up. What
the fuck's his name? The young dig.
The youngster there are the young
[inaudible], the young fellow there.
Right?
Who Do you like?
Who Do you like about it? That was a
fucking boat shows, you know what I mean?
Come on. Those are two of the sickest
shows I've been on. So anyways,
I went out there,
um,
and it was unreal and of
course like a fucking asshole.
I didn't get a picture with
anybody backstage. What an asshole.
At one point I'm talking to Louie and
Dave like two of my biggest standup heroes
and I got a fucking iPhone Ami
and I never thought to be like,
Hey, let's get a picture.
I never thought to do that.
Now I don't know all of these.
These next weekend I'm doing more of them
to pay for the fucking money pit.
I didn't want to get into that.
I'm not even going to get into that
because there's no comedy left in this
fucking project. Uh, Jesus,
I'm just,
when the job is done,
I'm going to go downstairs and I'm not
going to have any money to refurnish it
and I'm just going to stand
down there and in the echo,
I'm just going to start with.
Yeah.
Um, never again. Never again. I understand
why nobody did shit to this fucking
house because to try to fix it is
ridiculously expensive. And I am, I am.
I am fucking done with it. So anyways,
I, uh, I went out there,
I had a great time.
I was trying out new material and uh,
it was such a cool,
I didn't even realize how cool the venue
was until somebody took a picture from
the upper deck, the upper deck,
a fucking comedy show. How that,
that venue, uh, I'll actually,
I'll tweet it out. Um,
on the Monday morning podcasts,
Twitter, uh, handle there.
Whatever the fuck you kids
say at the m m podcast,
join our Twitter following.
We're only up to,
we're already up to 10,000
followers, you know, 10,000 more.
We can start a church. You guys
will start calling me father. Uh,
right. I'll grow a long white beard and
I'll start banging everybody who fucking,
you know,
everybody who was there.
That's what you do when you can't,
when you can't play an instrument,
when you can't tell jokes and you still
want to fuck everything that's moves.
Your only other option is
other than hookers, is you,
you have to start a religion.
That's basically what you do.
And you tell people what they want
to hear and you bring them in.
Okay.
And you tell them that there's this
higher thing and it cares about them,
it's going to help them. And,
but I'm the direct route to it.
You talk to me and I'll talk to with,
and I know it, it, it loves me and it,
whatever I say it's going to listen to
and I'm kind of it, you know what I mean?
I'm kind of it, but it's it. But I'm kind
of that thing. And next thing you know,
I'm it, I'm the, I'm the guy, I'm
Jesus. I'm the father, the son.
I'm the fucking house,
Funny Omega, I'm the fucking, uh,
Fox Trot and the fucking x Ray,
right?
Next thing you know,
you're blowing Jesus. Um, all right. So,
okay.
So we went ahead and we did
the, uh, we do the Gig and, uh,
I flew into New York Friday for the Gig,
6:00 AM flight,
and then I flew back 8:00 AM Saturday.
I like,
I landed at like three o'clock,
jumped in a cab traffic all
the way in to lower Manhattan,
Soho, drop my bags, jumped
in the shower, got ready,
ran downstairs, got in the
van, went out, did the Gig,
came back, smoked a cigar, Versie
stayed out until four in the morning,
went right to the fucking airport.
And that was, that was it right in.
And I got to tell you,
I had two of the greatest fucking
transcontinental flights I ever had.
I go to the airport,
right?
6:00 AM and I'm sitting there
like a fucking Zombie, right?
And there's a guy sitting
like two seats over.
He's sitting there like
all those people,
they don't sit on their ass.
They kind of sit on
their lower back and then the back of
their neck is at the top of the chair.
He was sitting there and his shirt was
up and he was showing his mid drift for
whatever fucking reason. So I want
to take a picture of this guy subtly.
You don't not show his head just so
it was awful belly sitting there.
This fucking legs at a 45 degree
angle and I want us, you know,
I was going to text one of my,
uh, Hashtag animal photos, right?
And of course right as they get the phone
out, he drops his shirt down. I'm like,
God damn it. You know, and I'm
hating life. I'm tired as shit.
And all of a sudden the lady at the a,
the desk just goes,
Mr. William Day, Kiki plead to pledge
the fucking guest here, please.
So I got shit, what are they going to
say that gave my fucking seat away?
And now I'm sitting on the toilet in
the back and I walked up and they,
they bumped me up to first class,
first forking clayish.
So I get on the plane and it's those
first class seats that are diagonal,
that fold all the way down into a bed.
So the second way airborne,
I fold this thing down into the
bed or unfolded, I should say,
put on my little sleep mask
and just fucking pass out.
I wake up three and a half hours later,
put the thing back up.
I ask if there's any breakfast left. They
say, yes there is. I've got some yogurt,
Granola and a fucking
egg and spinach quiche,
whatever the fuck it is.
It was delicious.
And then I watched Mike Tyson's one
man show and the second it ended,
we fucking land.
It was perfect fucking park by the way.
Mike Tyson's one man show. I got to talk
about that here in a second. Let me, uh,
let me get a little advertising out of
the way here. Um, all right. Legal Zoom,
everybody. Legal Zone. Don't have a will,
but why you don't want the court dictating
what happens to your property and
minor children do you? Of course you
don't. So why procrastinate? Well,
most people say, oh, too expensive
or too time consuming. You know what?
My answer is?
Legal zone.com.
Absolutely too expensive legal zooms
prices. They just make sense too.
Time consuming.
It only takes 20 minutes and legal
zoom guide you from start to finish.
You can't screw it up.
The service was developed by some of
the best legal minds in the country and
they make it painless for you to get
the legal help you need. In fact,
helping people get legally protected has
been their mission and passion for over
13 years during national
make a will month.
Get a special pricing on wills and
living trusts by entering burpee.
You are are in the referral
box at checkout. Again,
that discount code is bar.
It's national. Make a will month
for the rest of the year evidently.
So now I'll wait for text your family.
Protect your future@legalzoom.com today,
legal zoom was developed by top attorneys
to provide self help service at your
specific direction, but they
are not a law firm. Okay.
Legal help is furnished through
vetted independent attorneys.
Legal zoom.com code burpee you are are.
All right.
The next one. Our old buddies
here, our old buddies,
the Revolutionary Dollar Shave Club.
Ever wonder why razors are so expensive?
Huh?
Big Shave companies are charging you
for ridiculous shaving technology.
You don't even need first vibrating
handles. Then flashlights.
Now pivot ball, flex heads. You know,
what are they going to put in
there next and MP? Three player.
I'm enough is enough. Come on,
you don't need all that crap.
Joined Dollar Shave club.com
for a few bucks a month.
Dollar shave.com delivers the world's
best razors right to your door.
A dollar shave club.com blades are
better than the big shave companies for a
fraction of the price.
It's so easy.
Go to dollar shave club.com pick one of
their razors and they started just $3 a
month.
You don't need to break the bank.
It's a biggest scam there ever was.
Okay?
These damn blade should
be made out of gold.
The amount that they charge
at a drug store. Okay,
and you've got to go down to
the dam pharmacy to go get them.
Just stay in your house. They'll bring
them to you for a fraction of the cost.
You don't have to resort
to cheap disposable blades
to shape Safecast. Sorry.
Dollar Shave club.com is amazing.
Every month they ship you
your automatic delivery.
She'll never forget to buy blades again.
You don't have to squeeze shaves
out of adult dirty old razor blade.
You get to shave with a fresh blade
every week, which is so great for you.
Your cute little face there.
This is absolutely mandatory for
anyone that wants a great shave. Okay.
You deserve better than a dull blade.
Why don't you treat yourself no
more ridiculous shaving technology.
Make the smarter choice like I did.
Join the dollar shave
club.com/ [inaudible] or join
dollar shave club.com/burr
that's dollar shave club.com/bar.
All right.
All right. We got, what have we got? We
got two more, so read two more after that.
Am I reading the right ones? Ah, fuck me
thought there was a, I
read the wrong ones. Oh,
what an asshole.
Okay.
Legal Zoom. Okay. Well, no, no, I didn't
read it. And Dollar Shave Club. All right.
Those were two I supposed to do. I was
reading last week stuff, but thank God.
All right, those do count. So
listen to what I just said on those
[inaudible].
Don't save all right now
that's out of the fucking way.
Yeah.
Okay. Anyways, let's get back
to the Mike Tyson one man show.
If you haven't seen it, I
highly recommend it. Um,
it's a, I dunno, it's Mike
Tyson telling his story.
And what I loved about it was
there was times you love the
Guy Times you will, like,
I dunno about this Guy Times
you felt he was being sincere.
And then other times you're like,
this guy's, you know, as he says,
he was a hustler.
And I'm just sitting there going,
is he doing that right now
to me? And in the end, um,
you know, you don't know
it was, I don't know.
It was just a really, first
of all, what killed me was I,
I think Mitch Green or whatever
the fuck the name that back.
Remember that guy he punched
in the eye and closed his eyes.
He tells the whole fucking story and acts
out the other guy wearing a Jheri curl
wig and
just sit down and watch it and tell
me you don't see Charlie Murphy on the
Chappelle show,
you know,
and Dave Chappelle doing the ric
Charlie Murphy talking about fight.
And Rick James, I'm telling you, this is
his story, could literally be the sequel.
All I kept picturing was Dave
Chappelle reenacting this fight,
this epic fucking street
fight that started in a store,
ends up out in the street fucking with
the other dude on top of Tyson's car and
Tyson just giving up boxing and,
and I was just kicking the guy is there,
bolt on the ground. I mean, it was,
it was unbelievable story and fucking
hilarious. And I was sitting there going,
why is this guy do this?
There was a style with which that he
tells that story that was very reminiscent
of the way Charlie Murphy tells
a story. Then I'm like, well,
these guys are like within
five years of each other.
And they both grew up in Brooklyn
around the same time. And um,
I don't know. It's one of my favorite
things that I've seen in a while. Granted,
I was laying in a bed in FirstClass
eating a spinach and egg quiche,
you know, you know, Judah
Freelander said to me one time,
I watched some movie and I
was like, you know, I, well,
you know, I was on the plane.
You know what I watched?
I watched whatever movie and was a
movie that got bad reviews and uh, yeah,
I thought it was good.
I thought it was a good movie.
And they just starts laughing. And
I was like, why? He goes, Bill,
every movie is a good movie. When
you're on an airplane. He's like,
you're on an airplane.
You fucking hate in life.
You put this thing on and eats up an
hour and a half of your life. I'm like,
all right, fair enough. Fair enough.
But I got to say this, this, uh,
the Tyson one man show, which was
done on Hbo, uh, shot by spike Lee.
Um,
you know what's funny about Spike Lee's,
how we always trashes Tarantino about it,
how the characters dropping the
n words and that type of stuff.
If you want to see something funny is how,
how Spike Lee views Italians.
Like if Italians could be in black face,
like in [inaudible],
they should be in his movies
is they always like, Huh?
Oh well you feel good.
They're always wearing track suits
mama.
It's ridiculous.
I just watched summer sandwich.
I really liked that movie but I had to
hit mute when they're full and they were
fucking showing the Italians when they
was sitting down at that dead end street.
It will, it look like a fucking
bad musical from like 1953.
Um, so, you know, I think he,
I think he's got some work to do himself.
Oh, let me get some focused. Um,
all right, sorry. That's my little
criticisms. If you know, you know,
there's nothing better than someone
who's never made a fucking movie himself.
Never written one or anything.
Now I'm going to sit there and criticize
and one of the top directors out there.
Right. But anyways, he directed
that and I really enjoyed it. Um,
so check it out if you get a
chance, hey, you don't movie.
I wanted to see and I didn't get, I didn't
get a chance to see anything. You know,
I was going to go fucking a cozy planet
of the apes and root against the apes as
I was in the first one.
Okay.
I fucking hated, hated, uh,
James Franco's character
in that first one.
I couldn't stay like
I went and I saw it with Nia and
we're sitting there and once he, he,
he gave that fucking,
he gave that fucking ape like pants
and sneakers and shit. You know,
it was just like, dude, what
the f? What are you doing?
Yeah.
What the fuck? What are you
doing? You talking to a,
to an ape.
Don't give it pants.
All right?
You get, you can't, can't have the thing
fucking dress in as good as you are.
Jesus Christ did.
Didn't you learn anything from the British
how they built their empire on that
little shit? Ass fucking little island
out there ran the fucking world out.
Did they do it? Divide and
conquer. All right. Yeah.
You don't get to wear shoes.
Anybody at this levels get shoes,
but no pants.
Then the very best of all of you who
get to this level, get shoes and pants.
That's what they did.
And then the people with no shoes,
eight of the people with shows be wish
shoes for, you know, that's what you do,
you know, go into your fucking closet.
A a chimpanzee. Yeah, go ahead.
Pick it.
Pick yourself out of soup.
We'll go down to the track like fucking
Eric Roberts and Mickey Rourke and uh,
okay.
The fucking a, I dunno,
the King of Prince Street,
whatever the fucking name that movie was.
The fuck was the name of that movie.
The pope of Greenwich
Village. Every, you know,
sometimes I watch a movie and I go for
the ride and there's other times like,
people just do shit. That's just
so fucking dumb. It's just like,
I don't have any sympathy for,
you should get your face ripped off
fucking sitting there. You know,
you don't give a laptop to a monkey.
What's wrong with you?
Okay.
Think of all the Shit we've done to him.
You know,
you can teach them how to drive a car.
Okay.
Like how does that end? Um, anyways, yeah.
So I didn't see the second one. I'll go
to the one when we fucking defeat him.
You know, I'm a fair weather fan when it
comes to those eight movies. When the,
when the humans win, I'll, I'll, I'll,
I'll come back and I'll watch that one.
You know, I'll come by for the
playoffs. Playoffs. Um, anyways,
so after we do the,
uh,
after we do the Gig right
out there at Jones beach, um,
okay.
You know, I, I'm trying
to get back to, uh,
to New York as quickly as I can so I can
fucking go smoke the cigar with Versie
before I jump on a plane and
like fucking three hours. So, um,
Hardwick cat a car.
Okay.
So he goes, hey man. He goes, I'm
going to hang and watch the set.
We can ride back to the city together.
I'm like, perfect. So I go out, do my set.
Fucking unbelievable crowd
had a great time. It was like,
oddly like intimate.
It felt like a small crowd.
That crowd was so fucking amazing.
And um,
then I'll thank Christ. I didn't bomb,
I had a great set, I got out of there,
said goodbye,
didn't take any pictures like an asshole.
So I jumped in the car with Hardwick
and they gave us a police escort,
swear to God out of the
venue and up to the highway.
But this is what's funny.
The show is still going on so
there's completely no need for this.
And we are basically driving through a
full parking lot with nobody in our way
with the police car,
with its lights flashing.
And we sat that laugh. We're going, are
we wasting taxpayer money right now?
And we're like, no. Well I mean
they were hired here anyways,
so they were already hired for the event.
It's like,
what about the gas and the crows though?
So there you go.
I've got my first police escort,
you know,
and there was nobody there to witness
it other than me in hardware and our
driver, I swear to God
it happened, it happened.
It took me 22 years of this
business and it finally happened.
Just imagine Beatlemania
if nobody gave a fuck,
that's basically what we were
experiencing. We had the nice car,
we had the police escort and
other than the screaming fans,
you know, there was just sort of
a, yeah, there was a guardrail,
that's all I saw looking out the
window. Nobody saw it. Anyways,
let's plow ahead here.
So then I get back to the city.
Okay.
And, uh, I meet up with Versie
and another one of my buddies, uh,
Doug send, Yay. I'll be naming
names all over the place.
Two buddies of mine from
the standup world. And uh,
we go to the cigar bar and
have the time of our life in.
Both of them are golfers and they heard
what the fuck I said on my podcast or
whatever.
So we just start,
we just start going back and forth and
back and forth and back and forth arguing
this golf point. And I think I can
actually make my point a little,
I guess clearer.
And it's basically a why I considered
golf and activity a difficult activity.
Absolutely mentally taxing
activity without a fucking doubt.
I just,
I just feel like a,
you know when you don't have
to be any sort of cardio shape,
like you can be in whatever shape
you want to be and still win like a
championship.
You could be a fat fuck.
Okay.
Okay. And how are we going to say? Oh,
what about those offensive linemen?
That fat fucks.
Fuck you.
They can run a four 40 or a five
flat 40 those are fucking athletes.
Okay.
And they are that size like the way sumo
wrestlers are because they have to be
that size.
Okay.
They're told to get that fucking big.
All right.
Warren Sapp at his biggest weight could
still fucking wind dancing with the
stars. Okay. You're talking to an athlete
here. He's still light on his toes there.
All right. I'm talking how you can
just be a complete non athlete.
You can not even throw a fucking baseball
and, but you can be good at golf.
So or pool or bowling.
I lump all of those together.
They are a,
there are activities
with elements of sport.
It's like sport that you hit pause
on because there's no defender,
you know what I mean? And then picking
off, if somebody just says, you know,
Voss was saying, you
know that he goes, dude,
the other day I was out playing
golf and I shot in the meeting,
I was shooting in the mid eighties and
he got excited about shooting the mid
eighties and he goes, next thing you
know, I couldn't hit a shot. He goes,
there's no other game when that
happens. It's like, yeah, it does.
Not only does that happen in every other
fucking gay goes where you completely
forget out of the play the game.
Yes it does.
That happens in every other
sport and it happens in life.
It happens in up this man stand up comics
that have gone out to do a late night
talk show guts. So fucking in
their head, they forgot their act.
It's called choking in the moment,
you know,
I dunno, I probably be a great
golfer because I don't give a shit.
I don't respect the fucking game.
So I would never get in my
head, oh my God, I shot a 14.
Who gives a fuck? I'm not even keeping
score. I think that that's the dumb thing.
If you start keeping score
and out the whole thing,
it's like asked you if you're playing
cribbage out there and I just don't
understand the whole fucking thing.
I don't understand why people won't
come to my way of thinking of it.
Why don't you think my way? So whenever
we're arguing this fucking thing,
okay.
And uh,
just having a great time
and the night ends verse,
he drives me back down to the
hotel. We get out, I get a bacon,
egg and cheese
at like four in the morning and then
I walk into a Dunkin donuts and get a
chocolate glazed donuts. By the way,
people, I'm off the rails here, um,
with the Diet thing and I'm
starting to go back up again.
So I decided this morning,
I'm like,
I just have to step outside because
right now I got the crack in me.
I got the sugar salt thing. Look
at that Bacon, egg and cheese,
salt through the fucking roof. Oh, I
want a donut. I don't want a donut.
Nobody ever wants to fucking
doughnut unless this salts
through the fucking roof.
And I shoved that down my fucking pie
hole like homer Simpson and then I go
directly to bed. Horrific. Um,
so that was the end of the night.
Just had a great time. And uh,
so I oversee versus kind of, uh, he bought
this, you know, versus a sedan guy. Right.
Cause I was trying to convince him,
I was saying one of the coolest cars
out there right now is the Mercedes Benz
East 63 AMG formatics station wagon.
They made a station wagon
that goes zero to 60,
in like three and a half
fucking seconds to me. You know,
I got this like I love,
I love a fast car,
but I love a car that doesn't look
fast. That is fast. The fucking right.
Did I talk about this last week?
I can't remember.
So I was trying to tell him why that car
was the shit and how funny it is if he
owned that fucking car. You know, if
you're married with kids, you know,
and you pull up next to some punk and
they see you there with your fucking
station wagon and then you blow
him off the line, you know,
groceries flying out the back end. I
just think that they know, and I'm,
I'm German. Right. And that's
the great thing about Germans,
you know,
is their fucking,
their ability with science is incredible.
You know,
they're not the best to get along
with people. Absolutely. Okay.
But who the fuck makes a station wagon
that goes zero to 60 in like 3.8 seconds?
The fucking Germans
got to love,
you know, you get dead, you get yourself
some strudel or a fucking Reuben there.
I mean, what, what else do you need?
Sorry. So anyways, um, he's
got this four door sedan, man,
and I'm telling you it's a fucking
bad ass car. But I kept, he's got it.
He's got to get some rims on
it, you know? So I said to him,
I was going to bring it up.
All right, I'm going to get,
this is what I want to
try to use the power,
what little power I have on this podcast
to get Paul Versey to get rid of his,
his fucking, I'm a 55 year old. Awful.
I'm a 55 year old man. Awful rims on
his car. So if you have a rim shot,
a rim, a rim shop, a rim
shot, it's a drumming thing.
If you have, if you have a few
owners store and you sell rims,
okay? Can you hook my boy Versie
up if you hook them up? Okay.
If you give them a sweetheart
of a fucking deal, okay.
For some rims on his car,
you can advertise for free for two
weeks on a Monday morning podcast.
I bought that. Okay. I'm
throwing it out there.
You got to hook up
Paul. Dude, I called it,
don't say I'm from Jersey.
Versie okay.
Hook 'em up because I like his cars,
but his rims annoy me and they're going
to affect their fucking friendship there.
I said it all right. Um, all
right, let's plow ahead here.
Where are we in the podcast? 39 minutes.
Oh Jesus. I think it's time for a,
I think it's time for some more letters.
Let me just bang out these last two, uh,
advertising things.
I love this advertising here because this,
this reminds me how close football
season ends is, uh, is coming here.
Draft kings, everybody.
The wait is almost over.
Football season is just around the
corner and you could get your piece of 5
million bucks.
During kickoff,
we had draft kings.com America's
favorite one week fantasy football site.
You've already been scouting players
and doing research for your season long
team. Uh, use that knowledge to when
instant cash the first week of the
season@draftking.com last year one player
turned 11 bucks into four grand in one
weekend.
Another player won a million bucks in
one day just playing fantasy football.
All right, who's kitten hope? People you
play in fantasy football. You're a nerd.
All right. You want to make it
better and I can actually wait.
Now you can make some money now. It makes
sense. Okay. Rather than screaming it,
your friends in your pajamas, you can
actually win some serious money here.
You want enough money here?
You could buy a frigging team.
Fantasy football is exciting,
but it's way more exciting.
A draft king.com where you can win huge
cash starting the first week of the
season. Don't miss out on the week.
One excitement. Reserve your spot now.
Uh, bounce over to draft king.com.
Enter the Promo Code d fence.
It's very hard to only say that word
once and you'll get free entry into the
week. One $5 million kickoff bash
draft, king.com bigger events,
bigger winnings, bigger millionaires.
Enter defense. All in caps,
a for free entry
now@draftkingdotcomdraftking.com
and lastly,
but not leastly the old favorites
here and the Monday morning podcast.
Where the hell are they? Where
are they? stamps.com everybody.
You know that feeling you get when,
uh,
when you can get things done
with the click of your mouse,
it can't get more convenient
than that candidate.
And now you can even get your mailing
and shipping done without ever leaving
your desk.
Thanks to stamps.com stamps.com turns
your PC or Mac into your own personal post
office that never closes.
Talk about convenient buy and print
official us postage for any letter or
package using your
computer and your printer.
Then just hand your mail to the mailman
or drop it in the mailbox and you'll
never have to go to the post office again.
I use stamps.com to send out
all my posters, my tee shirts,
whatever crap I'm selling at the end of
the show. I am a moron if I can do this.
So can you. It's that easy
right now. Use My last name.
Burpee you are are for this special offer,
no risk trial plus a $110 bonus offer
that includes a digital scale that
calculates exact postage for letters
and packages and up to $55 free postage.
Don't wait. Go to stamps.com
before you do anything else, uh,
click on the top Mike. Oh, I thought
he just tipped over glass. Um,
click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburbburthatstamps.com
enter
burr. He was actually
a box of Kleenex. What,
do you have a box of Kleenex next to
your bed bill for when you jerk off? No,
when I cry myself to sleep.
Yeah.
Um, all right, let's get to
the, um, let's get to the,
uh, the reads for the week. Once again,
if you'd like to follow the podcast,
everybody on Twitter,
our handle is at the m m podcast.
That is our Twitter following.
We put all the links up to the videos.
You put all the links up for, uh,
whatever the hell I brought up this
week or that picture of Jones beach.
We're going to have
that up there. And, um,
if you'd like to donate to the
podcast while not, you know,
and forgets something for your money,
just go to [inaudible] dot com click on
the podcast page and next time you want
to go to amazon.com we
have an Amazon banner.
You just click on that thing
takes you right to the site.
I get credit for driving
traffic to their site.
You don't have to pay any extra
money if you buy something, you know,
it comes my way. They kicked me a
little bit of something. All right. Um,
okay.
And with that, let's, uh,
let's get to the letters here.
Alright, girl, smokes a lot of weed.
Hey Cincinnati bow tie. Billy. I
don't even know what that means.
I gotta look that up.
Um,
I had been with my girlfriend for two
years and lived with her for about a year
and a half.
She has smoked weed since the day we met,
which doesn't bother me
because I used to smoke myself.
What bothers me is how many times
she smokes in, in a given day.
We will sometimes be hanging out watching
TV and she will out of nowhere get up
to grab her bowl to take a hit.
I've even caught her getting out of bed
in the middle of the night to take a hit.
I don't want to be a dick and tell
her she can't smoke after all.
I used to smoke myself. Uh,
she just looks like a drug fee.
Always trying to get a fix. I don't
get why she has to be high 24, seven.
I have a beer,
one beer after work,
maybe one to two days a week and sometimes
she will throw that in my face if I
comment about her constant weed smoking,
which isn't even close to the same thing.
I've always said this about weed smokers.
I've always said that about them.
Like the level that they get,
they get fucking high at work. Not all
of them. I'm just saying, you know,
like they'll fucking go out.
That'd be like if I went out in the
parking lot and shotgun a beer and came in
like with booze on my breath.
Um,
and it is addictive not to everybody,
but you can become addicted but sounds
like she is addicted to this shit.
Like she needs it to help her sleep.
She needs it so she can fucking deal man.
Um,
anyway,
she goes some egos sometimes she'll throw
that in my face if I comment about her
constant weed smoking,
which isn't even close to the same thing.
She also complains that she is broke.
It has no problem spending $100
on a bag of weed, a bag of weed.
What kills me is she will
sometimes ask me to help,
I'll help her out with the
bill or whatever, and I'm
just like, what the fuck?
How about you don't buy weed?
Our relationship is great.
This isn't a deal breaker or anything.
It's just an annoyance.
Should I just deal with it or should I
try to get her to chill out with weed?
What would you do with the lovely
Nia smoked weed all day? Thanks.
Go Fuck Yourself. I would address it.
I will definitely address it. Okay.
MMM.
Yeah,
she has a problem with that shit.
If you're waking up in the middle of
the night and taken another hit. I mean
I always just acquainted to drinking
because for some odd reason people can see
alcoholism,
but they can't see addiction with weed.
MMM.
If you were with somebody and in the
middle of the night they got up and poured
themselves a belt or to,
you know,
a couple of fingers of Scotch and
slammed it and then went back to sleep or
right in the middle of a movie they went
over and just fucking shotgun to beer.
And I that cause that's
basically what they're doing.
It's not like they go out and make a drink
in there sipping it. They're not that,
you know, they're getting high.
Then I gradually getting drunk.
It's like you do it. Bump. Yeah. Hi. Um,
and if she's doing it all the
time and she doesn't have,
she's not making any money and then she
asking you to help her out. I mean, if,
what if you didn't have a job and you
were drinking at the level that she was
smoking and you were spending 100
bucks on beer every week and sometimes,
you know,
you would ask her for help.
MMM.
What would she do? She would be
upset. Now this is what I would do.
I would bring it up with her.
She's gonna get mad and this is the thing,
you cannot get mad too if she yells
and calls you names and everything,
just do not get mad.
Just sit there and know that she is,
you know,
you're going to lose the fight.
Okay?
If you bring up her weed
smoking and then she's like,
you know what the fuck you fucking blah
blah blah blah blah blah. And then a few,
if you go to where the fuck she is there,
you're going to lose because then it's
become a name calling thing and you know
she is successfully gotten it out of the
arena of what she's doing is fucked up.
Uh, yeah. You just need to stay
in the pocket and be like, listen,
I don't mind that you smoke
weed. I drink beer. Okay,
but you are smoking weed 24,
seven you're getting up in the middle
of the night and you're smoking weed and
I'm worried about you and
you're asking me on some time,
you're blowing $100 a week on weed and
you're asking me to help you out sometime.
Okay. Now, in all fairness,
if I was blowing 100 bucks on beer
every week and I was, you know,
waking up in the middle of
the night drinking a beer
and they're going to pull that shit
dead isn't the same thing. Yes it is.
It is the same thing. You're altering
your mental state with alcohol,
but you said if you're using your,
your, you're using marijuana. All right.
And uh, you know, I care about you and
you're kind of going down. You know,
it's basically,
it's your job to keep your woman in line
and it's her job to keep you in line.
And that isn't some sexist shit
by when I say keep you in line,
which just means when they
see you going out of bounds,
they see you going up river a little
bit like Colonel Kurtz Shaving your head
gone. The horror is you sit there in
the corner, fucking shotgun a beer.
It's her job to be like, I
think you, you're starting to,
your drinking is getting
a little out of control.
That's what you do when you love somebody.
So just know that she might not be
ready to hear that shit, but you know,
she asked to hear it from you.
You're just trying to help her out.
And if she flips out and calls you a
bunch of names, just say, listen, let's,
I've said what I had to say.
I'm more than willing to discuss this
with you later when you've calmed down,
but I'm not going to
get into a name calling.
Okay.
Uh,
argument with you.
And you leave it at that and
then they have no fucking choice.
They have no choice other than to
just fucking chill at that point.
Or they continue calling you names.
But after that, they're gonna,
they're gonna owe you an apology.
All right?
And if they don't apologize and
they can't admit that they're wrong,
that's a whole other fucking red flag,
you know?
Cause I couldn't be in a fucking
relationship with somebody who,
you know, if they fuck up, can't
be like, all right, you know what,
you will write on that one. You
know, you've got to have that.
If you don't have that, I don't know what
the fuck you go. So good luck with that,
sir. All right, next
one. What the fuck to do?
Serber loved the show
and listen to weekly.
Thanks for making my money's entertaining.
Well, you're welcome. All right.
I am 39 and separated with the child
and I started seeing a woman who was 43
divorced with their own child, but
uh, but up, up, here's this story.
About two months into the relationship
we were getting serious and we started
discussing a future together.
However,
our relationship started to erode about
as quickly as it started and we ended up
breaking up after dating
a total of six months.
One of the reasons we ended things was
that we didn't agree on wanting more kids.
She wanted more,
but I didn't,
we ended on such a bad note that
we agreed to not talk anymore.
Um, okay. At this point I'm like, good.
That was a very mature relationship.
Okay.
Early on. You said what you both
wanted, you realize that you didn't,
you want it to different
things and you walked,
got a little ugly there for a second.
But who gives a fuck? Anyways?
He goes, as luck would have it, about
two to three weeks after we broke up,
she called me to tell me she is pregnant.
Oh my God.
Wait a minute.
She wanted more than I did and
she pulled the goalie. A dude.
You didn't want more kids. You didn't
use a condom. Oh my God. She go,
he goes, I did not know how
it was possible. Okay, cool.
Cause we took precautions,
but I guess I slipped up.
I slip one past the goalie.
I was devastated and worried because
not only do I not want more kids,
my current financial situation would limit
me greatly in my ability to take care
of my child and another child.
My question to you is,
what the fuck do I do?
Uh,
I would get a paternity test.
Definitely get a paternity
test to make sure it's yours.
Um, if you don't want to, I mean
that's, and that's a prayer.
I'm not saying anything bad about
this woman, but just, you know,
you got to throw the Hail Mary here
and hope maybe you get lucky. He goes,
my question to you is,
what the fuck do I do?
She doesn't want to have an abortion at
told me that we should get back together
and have the baby.
Is she lying? She said, if not,
she would try to legally prevent me from
having a part being part of the
child's life. As I was writing this,
she was about six weeks pregnant,
so a lot of time,
a lot of time to stress about it.
Um, yeah dude, fuck all of that.
She's going to wait a minute. Let me just
read the last paragraph. This, he goes,
I'm not stupid enough to go to
a comedian for advice. However,
I do think you have an
interesting perspective on
life and I'd love to hear your
point of view.
This situation has since been resolved.
See below to see how it turned out.
But the,
but answered the question before you see
the result. Thanks. And Go fuck yourself.
Well, I don't see the results here. Below.
I'd love to know what happened. Jesus.
Now you're leaving me hanging in
there. All my listeners, all right,
here's my thing. If any
woman said, you know,
you got me pregnant and I didn't
want to be with her and she said,
uh, if you, if you don't live with me and
we have a relationship, you'll never see,
uh, the kid. I would just be like,
that's no way to go into a relationship,
okay? You want to find love, okay.
And the way to find true love is
not to hold somebody hostage, okay,
we made a mistake.
Now we're going to be adults and
we're going to raise this child in an
unconventional way because
we do not love each other.
So it's not going to be fair to the kid.
We're both together.
It also will not be fair to the kid
if you prevent the kid from seeing the
mother, his mother or his father, okay?
So we need to be adults and put this kid
first and set aside our differences and
be as mature about this
as we possibly can.
The next 18 years are critical in this
kid's life. And we need to suck it up.
All right,
so let's get on the same damn page here.
All right.
I mean, somewhere along the
lines, I would, I would say that,
but I would definitely get a
fucking paternity test. Um,
cause you never know what
somebody's doing. And, uh, you know,
you kind of seem like dumbfounded
that she actually got a pregnant.
Who knows what happens.
She seems like she wants more kids.
She could be this desperate person
that was, you know, I don't know what,
but a stranger things have happened. So
I would definitely get a paternity test.
And if she gets mad fucker,
who gives a shit?
Yeah.
If she gets mad, it'd be like, listen,
you know, you shouldn't say this,
but in your head you've gotta be thinking
this is somebody who is fucking crazy
enough to basically
threaten me into her life.
If you're crazy enough to do that,
you're crazy enough to say a kid
that isn't mine is mine. Okay.
She's not acting stable right now.
So
I dunno.
And that is healthy paranoia.
That is not, uh, you know,
you know, if I ever said some
shit like that on the view,
okay.
You know what kills me is they would just,
they would tow the company line,
but I swear to God backstage,
you know, bitches is crazy.
Um, Phil Collins and Genesis, uh, oh
by the way, we're talking dramas here.
I didn't realize this. I um, I
just got tickets to go see Primus,
a band that I've always
been meaning to see and uh,
Tim Herb Alexander's back in the band
and I loved the way that that guy always
love the way that guy he's played.
And um, I got some tickets.
Me and roses. Joey roses are
going Joey roses by the way,
who has a new comedy CD coming out,
I believe September 2nd.
He's going to give me all the details,
but I'm go to Joe to Rosa
comedy.com I believe is his website.
I don't know what his fucking website is.
Why don't I do a better job promoting
an old pals fucking website,
but actually having a decency
of looking it up here.
Sorry for the poor audio
quality right now. All right.
Joe Doe Rosa has a website.
I don't know what it's fucking called.
You call yourself. Yeah. Jody
rose a comedy.com. All right,
let's see what he's got here.
Okay.
He has some shoulders.
Body lacks the meat between
his neck and ball socket.
All right, where do we go here? Why is
my fucking Internet so God damn slow,
whatever it's showed a rosa,
comedy.com.
He's got a new fucking comedy
CD coming out and a God damn.
And I stand behind it as does
everybody else here on this podcast,
but should basically be me. But anyways,
so, uh, I, I didn't realize that,
uh, Tim Alexander had a heart attack. Um,
but he's doing great and
he's recovering well. Uh,
judging by the stuff that I've seen him
post on his Twitter account and that
type of thing,
uh,
I'm really happy for him because he's
truly is one of the great drummers are the
lives. Uh, 24 years. Jesus Christ.
Has it been that long since? Uh,
I've been listening to him, but, um, so
whatever, if this somehow gets to them,
happy to hear that you're doing well
and, uh, continued healthy lifestyle.
A righty. Okay. I'm Phil Collins
and genesis may have been done.
Oh, by the way, thank you to everybody
that also donated to a Benny grubs.
Um, DVD. He's, he's, he needs like
a, he's raised 99% of the money,
so that really means a lot to me and uh,
it's going to help other drummers,
which will help music, which we'll come
back around. Even if you don't play drums,
you get to listen to better drummers,
make it better music. So, uh,
I really appreciate everybody who donated.
That was pretty awesome. All right.
Okay,
last time starting this bill.
Phil Collins and genesis may have been
done before, but hey, Billy Bruford,
you're a drummer. Stupid.
You must know him. I am.
You'd have to insult me because your,
you felt insecure about
your obscure reference. Um,
all right.
On last week's podcast,
you brought up Mr Phil
Collins and genesis.
You absolutely nailed how
incredible Phil is as a drummer.
I am an early genesis fanatic from
trespass nursery crime foxtrot selling in
England by the pound and the lamb
lies down on Broadway and he has in
parentheses dope.
You know what's funny is I don't
know anything about early genesis.
I just know Phil Collins is
a fucking amazing drummer.
I know that they were a a prog
rock band and that Peter Gabriel,
who later sung sledgehammer gave himself
a reverse Mohawk at some point when he
was in that band. Anyways, he
says that dude, as you may guess,
should be boss, Mo Bostonian
because it's the best album. Oh,
the lamb lies down on Broadway dough.
That's what,
that's how that was supposed to be red.
All right, well I'll check that one out.
Anyways,
he said when Peter Gabriel left the band
in 1975 these guys audition singers for
months. No one could get it right.
So what it old Phil Collins do,
he stepped out from behind the drum kit
like a bad ass and took over the role as
front man and drummer from there. They
remain true to their roots for a while,
I'd say at least three to four albums.
And until of course, as you pointed out,
the cash cow came along and they climbed
aboard the proverbial money train. Uh,
but that should,
but that should not discredit these guys.
They have my ultimate respect.
It gives a fucking, in the end,
you finally wanted to get paid and go
out and get yourself a fucking station
wagon that went zero to 60 in 3.5 seconds.
I totally get that.
You know, and Phil Collins kept it real.
He never got hair plugs are a toupee.
He just held onto that landing
strip forever. Um, however,
that's not to mention, uh, however,
that's not to mention brand x,
which was Phil's jazz fusion side project.
That's where his drumming
really flourished. The
album product is a must do.
This is like some hardcore music Geek
Shit, and I'm loving every second of this.
Um, Phil always surrounded himself with
brilliant drummers bay there, Cleo,
Bill Bruford there,
and a chest to Thompson of Zappa fame.
Not to mention that bitch
and Tarzan theme, right?
No Tarzan theme. Tarzan. I'm sorry,
I've been out here too long.
Stick and Tarzana.
Okay.
Um, Thursday, August 21st genesis
posted to their official Facebook page,
a new logo and a promise
for exciting news.
Summer speculated a possible
reunion with the 71 to 75 lineup,
including Peter Gabriel and Steve Hackett,
which I would come buckets forth.
Jesus Christ. Dude, I don't
need that visual. He said,
I am a musician bill and I love
when you bring up your drumming,
you bring your drumming up and
music and Jen will keep it up.
And the Mike and the mechanics
named Mike and the mechanics.
Dude's name is Mike Rutherford. How
British can you get cozy, smug cunt?
Um, I am uh, yeah, I love
all that type of shit.
Do you know I'm going to do another
one of those goddamn comedy jams.
I can't figure out what
song I'm going to do. Um,
but some of the songs I've been messing
with have double bass in them and uh,
that's something that,
uh,
when it comes to double bass
drumming, I am, I am a snob.
Okay.
When it comes to it,
I'm actually a cunt.
When it comes to double bass drumming
because I can't do it on any level,
but I have some hardcore
opinions about it.
MMM.
I don't like when somebody uses it to
enhance all their fucking fills around the
kit, just running underneath that,
just doing the quad thing or whatever.
Like I that always annoyed me
because it makes you sound,
you're doing these bottom quads,
but I know you kind of cheat.
But uh,
however,
if you get somebody who actually utilize
it to enhance a groove or even a fill,
like I would say, uh, Tim Alexander,
like some of the drumming that
that guys recorded is, is just,
it's astounding. Like, I feel like,
like I kinda got into this thing where
I felt guys who played single bass drum
could play a better groove then somebody
that played double bass because they,
I'm trying to, I, how do I equate
if you just had this extra f,
it's like he had this Howard
Sir underneath you and
they just couldn't resist
jumping on those fucking things every
chance they had to do some insane
sounding.
Phil and I always felt like the guys,
I just felt like the guys that had the
least amount of shit played the best,
like a Steve Jordan, you know, it
played a little four piece kit.
I mean that guy could literally,
you could just give them a high hat,
a ride Cymbal, Bass Drum and snare,
like a quest love, same thing.
And that guy could get more goddamn music
out of it than some guy that has like
a 50 piece set. Like I kind of
went into that and then, which was,
there was an element of truth to it,
but it was a,
it was an arrogant like mindset.
It would be the same thing as that.
There'd be like a clean comic is better
than a dirty comic and you're not
listening to what they're saying. So, uh,
I've actually come around now and
there's a bunch of players that, uh,
that I like, but it's, but like, if
there's no groove, I can't get into it.
If he just fucking plane
like a zillion miles an hour,
like I've got to admit like those, uh,
those blast beats and that type of thing,
that's fucking insane
that somebody can do that.
But after a while it's just
played so fucking fast.
I, it all sounds the same. Maybe I need
to listen to more of it to be able to, uh,
hear it.
But my favorite part and death metal is
when the singer for like half a second,
you actually hear what his singing voice
really sounds like before he goes back
to that type of shit. So, um,
anyways, um, so I've been,
I'm fucking around with some,
uh, some of that double
Bass Shit. I'm not,
I'm not going to say
what it is because uh,
you know the reveal like I guess I wasn't
supposed to say that I was going to
dress up like Tommy Lee last week.
Um, did I talk about that by the way?
We fucking, we smashed it, man.
We got off to have a little rough start.
I fucked. I always fuck up the beginning.
Um, but I was psyched because I fucked
it up in that I didn't stop and I was
supposed to then restart,
but I just kinda kept going.
And if you didn't know the song,
you wouldn't notice that we fucked up.
So I felt good about that. And
uh, and you know, once again,
it took us a second,
then we got on track.
It's just kinda hard to come walking
out and be doing standup and then finish
that and then walk behind the
kitten that count off a band enough.
Fuck it up at my, at my drumming level.
It's a very difficult thing to do.
Uh,
hang on a second. I've been given
a note here. Need to get my stuff.
Okay. All right, I'll see. Um, anyways,
so let's go, let's go. Let's plow
ahead here. All right, girls stock.
Hi Mr Belt. I'm from the Czech Republic.
Well, how are you? How's it going?
Do you ever go up to a hungry and get
some of that fucking a art deco furniture
that they send over?
What does it from Budapest,
you don't charge us a fucking zillion
dollars for it anyways. He goes,
I listened to the mandate Monday morning
podcast like every single week and I
love what you're doing.
Well thank you. He goes,
I know you don't owe me anything but
I really need some advice right now.
Yes I do all you because you're walking
around the Czech Republic going,
have you fucking heard about
this redheaded cont over
there in the states and
some day I'll do a gig in Prague.
You guys got a funny bone over
there cause I'll do it. And he said,
there's a chick living in my
neighborhood and she's really into me.
I mean a lot in much more.
I would like to also say your English
was fucking unreal and I wasn't believing
that you were from the Czech
Republic by going, this is,
there was a chick living
in my neighborhood. You're
using the slang properly
and he then the next sentence he goes,
I mean a lot and much
more I would like to.
All right.
She calls me in the middle of the night,
keeps knocking on my door,
calling my name,
throws rocks at my window and once
climbed on a tree next to my house,
came inside my room and wait,
waited under my bed until I arrived.
Yeah, dude, you can't have
this. That's fucking creepy.
I didn't even know she wasn't
barefoot. Was She? She's barefoot.
I think she's a vampire.
You don't have to always barefoot and
they have like their breadth is cold.
I Dunno how Jesus,
he goes,
I didn't even know there is
something like girls stocking,
but now I'm starting to be worried.
The only thing I did was helping her
back on her feet when she fade out on my
friend's party couple of months ago.
I don't want to be mean or hurt her
feelings. She's pretty nice girl.
But this is way over the line. Any advice?
Yeah, you got to tell her to screw.
MMM.
You have to totally cut her off and
he can't have any interaction with her
because any sort of interaction with
this woman is going to make her feel like
you guys had dead justifies her
relationship. You know what I mean?
Um,
I feel bad that she's in this mind state,
but you don't have to deal with it. Uh,
first of all,
lock your fucking window and um,
if she ever comes in your house again,
you need to call the cops.
I would stand outside and have the cops
go in and get her out and I would have
legal record that that's what she did.
Okay. And then don't talk to her at all.
Don't answer the phone.
Don't nothing,
nothing.
And you have to, you have to cut
her out of your life because, uh,
she's out of her fucking mind.
All right. That's what I would do.
And when she cries or does whatever,
do not comfort her and go, I'm sorry,
but I'm just not into you.
Because in her world,
the relationship just started over again.
You have to fucking you up to.
You got to cut the head off
the snake and it, alright.
There you go. All right. When
is too old to start a band?
Okay,
well listen, I just started playing
out with, I'm out in a band,
but I got to tell you dude,
it was fucking,
I got to tell you some going down and
doing that goddamn comedy jam is sitting
in with the band is the most fun
Shit I've done in a long time.
I literally drive down there with like
butterflies, like this nervous excitement.
I,
you know how long it's been since I've
had that I've getting outside my comfort
zone and uh, I know obviously I'm
not going to join a band or anything,
but whatever that experience
is artistically is going
to help me in my acting.
It's somewhere down the road.
That experience is going
to fucking help me. And um,
okay.
I don't know. It's just the, it's
the fucking best. Anyway, so he goes,
when is too old to start a band? He
goes, hey bill, my boyfriend, oh,
she says, sorry. Oh Nice. A
female wrote in, God dammit,
I love when this happens.
This is my boyfriend of two years,
has been involved in is always, it's
been very involved in theater and music.
He was in bands throughout high school
and college as a drummer about a year ago
he joined a cover band, which
I'm totally supportive of. Uh,
it's a really nice hobby and
I love going to his shows.
Now we're getting pretty close
to two moving in together. Um,
he talks at length about
our future that um,
what we need to do to get there,
et cetera.
Basically we are being grown ups and
despite what you're probably thinking,
he is actually the one that brings
up our future and more than me.
I'm not judging you. I know I'm
[inaudible] but I'm not judging here.
I'm reading this open mindedly
he goes, well, she goes,
well I'm leaving this open.
Mindedly is, I keep calling you. He,
she says this,
um,
well about a week ago he
says that he and the chicken,
the cover band want to start their own
two person original band and based on
certain things he has said,
he seems pretty serious about
trying to make something of it. I,
he comments about me going on tour
with him or about becoming a rich music
musician, et cetera. My
first reaction, you're 31,
you don't really like your job much.
Parentheses,
people that hate their careers tend
to want to try something else. Uh,
you talked to me about our future
and what we have to do to get there.
You want to start dedicating
your time to a two person band.
I haven't said any of this to him
because I don't want to come off as
unsupportive,
but I mean at what age do you face the
reality and stop trying to live out of 15
year old's dream?
Granted,
it seemed very unlikely that anything
will come of it. Sorry, just being honest,
but doesn't this seem like a
midlife crisis? 10 years too early,
I should mention.
He also sent me this horrendous skull
tattoo today that he suddenly wants on his
arm a or am I being selfish
and an asshole? Be Blunt.
I can take it. All right. Um,
there's a lot of shit
going on in this one.
MMM.
Is 31 to late to start in a band?
Technically, no, I don't think it is.
MMM.
And
when you said you know that he's
having a midlife crisis, um,
I hate that expression.
MMM.
And however, I actually, I,
I at first I didn't like that you used
it until he was talking about getting the
awful skull tattoo on his arm that gave,
that loaned a lot of Krill.
That credibility too.
Uh,
the midlife crisis comment,
I would say this,
I think this is a person that,
yeah.
Wanted to be in a band, a successful
band, and is now 31 and is realizing like,
fuck, if I'm going to do
this, I need to do this now.
Yeah.
All right.
MMM.
But going out and getting the skull
tattoo, is it that really, I dunno.
I Dunno about that part.
That's making me feel like your assessment
of the situation and me without me
seeing this guy play, I
can't tell you. But like
mmm,
at this point he's in a cover band
and he has a job and that is your
relationship.
This guy has a job,
he has a steady income
and he has his cover band.
Now all of a sudden he's
going to give skull tattoo,
quit his job and potentially go
on the road and take you with him.
Now I'm assuming you have a fucking job.
So he is creating an entirely new dynamic.
So you're in the right to be like,
what the fuck are we doing here?
MMM.
And you're in a tough position where
you don't want to be like, listen,
this dream that you've had,
but for some reason it didn't go after
it the way you should have. You know,
I understand being in a cover band to
like pay the fucking bills, but you know,
if you're not making original music,
there's only so far that you can fucking
go as far as my understanding of it.
Um,
so
I actually, I don't think
that you're being an asshole.
Okay.
The skull tattoo thing is really
like a major fucking red flag to me
that uh,
does he have any other tattoos?
Fee,
doesn't have any other tattoos and
out of nowhere he's like, all right,
I'm going to stop being
in this cover band.
I'm going to finally take this fucking
thing seriously and I'm going to go out
and get some fucking awful
God damn tattoo. Yeah.
I would be kind of concerned about
the guy and what he was doing,
but as far as the whole
midlife crisis thing,
that gets thrown around a lot when
somebody goes after a dream and there's
nothing wrong with being 31 years
old and then to assessing your life,
being like, wait a minute, I've been
on this road, I don't want to go on.
I need to go on this other road.
And I think a lot of times people who
aren't going after a dream can't relate to
it.
I'm saying this is you,
but they can't relate to somebody going
after a dream and taking a big risk.
And they attributed to having a midlife
crisis or they don't have a dream,
they're just going to work and that's
fine working for somebody else and,
and you know,
doing the nine to five grind,
as long as you make enough money and you
have your benefits and you like where
you live, like that's fine. Like that's
your dream and they can understand,
um, somebody going after
something. But, um,
I would definitely not call it
a Midland.
I Dunno. I guess it is technically
a midlife crisis. I mean,
I'm doing all a midlife crisis is like,
fuck,
I better get on the stick or the
things that I wanted in life.
I'm not going to have,
it's like,
you know me when I'm sitting
here talking about you,
I'm finally going to get myself a nice
fucking car if I can ever get finished
with this God downstairs.
And you know,
I'm talking about some of the cars
that I'm looking at, you know,
and it just comes to, it's like if I don't
ever do this, I'm never going to do it.
I think when you're young you can
be like, oh, I'll do this someday.
I'll do this someday. Someday I'm going
to do this. She can lie to yourself and
in life you have to understand
that, no, if I don't do this,
I'm never going to do this.
Okay.
Does that make sense? If I don't
go over to fucking Europe, I'm not,
I'm never going to go to Europe unless
I get my fucking ass over there.
I'm never going to have this car that
I always wanted unless I go down to the
dealership and fucking
by the goddamn thing. Um,
in an hour and on.
People see you.
When people see you step out of what
they think that you are, which is,
I play in a cover band and I have
this job that I fucking don't like.
It's very easily to say,
are you having a midlife crisis?
He could also be having an awakening.
Okay,
so this is a very delicate thing.
Oh man,
it just keeps coming back to
that awful skulled tattoo. To me,
that just seems like, first of all, that's
the hackiest fucking tattoo out there.
You know, to get, you know,
fucking I'm in music to like die.
What's going to be a guy with
a skull fucking playing drums?
I mean that's just bad.
And I just look at that like you're
dressing up like a rock star rather than
legitimately being one. And um, I
don't think you're being a dick here.
I think what you're an asshole.
I think what you're
doing is he's going to,
he's making this big decision that's
going to affect both of your lives in a
major way so you're
not being a an asshole.
So right now what you have to do is
literally try to like defuse a bomb.
Okay? You got to make sure
you cut the right wire.
And what I mean by that is you're able
to convey your concerns. Like, listen,
I support you and all of that.
And I know you don't like to day job,
but you know, I mean, there's
just no way to say yes, 31,
you know,
you are 31 years of age.
MMM.
I would say,
look,
he's kind of making a move from himself
here. So you gotta make a move yourself.
What I would do is it's like I would talk
him out of the skull Tattoo. Just say,
listen, this is, this is how you decide
to get rid of the skull tattoo. Just say,
listen, I will support you. Okay.
You get with this woman, you guys
start making this fucking music. Okay,
but you're not getting the skull tattoo.
Yeah.
All right.
And then go down and watch them.
And if they seem like they have something,
who the fuck knows stranger
things have happened?
I would never tell somebody
not to go after a dream.
I would tell them not to get
the skull fucking Tattoo,
but a see if they have something,
even if it seems like they have something,
then I don't know.
Yeah,
I dunno. I, I don't
know that is that as a,
that is it then I guess
you have to assess,
do I want to take this fucking ride
because that is a motherfucker of a ride.
Um,
okay.
Yeah, that's, that's
what, uh, that's, I guess
I kind of was all over the map there,
but I think I came to a point,
no skull tattoo.
You can start making this fucking
original music together and like,
I mean,
I dunno,
how do you go out on the fucking road
unless you were actually doing well,
what are they going to do? You know,
they have to make some great music.
Um, I would just lay it on the line.
It's like you're asking me, you're,
you're making a major change here where
music was your hobby and now you're
going to make it your full time thing
and you're talking about taking me out on
the road. How are we going to afford to
do this and all of that type of stuff. Um,
I will support you making
them the original music,
but you are by no means getting a skull
tattoo on your fucking arm because that
is a, that is the tramp
tramp stamp for a guy. Okay.
Unless you're in a motorcycle
gang and you murdered somebody,
like there should not be any skulls on
your body. All right. There. I said it.
Okay. And that's it. That's the
Monday morning podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves. Football, bup,
bup, bup balls around the corner.
CanNot wait for college football
and all of that type of shit. Um,
that's it. I got nothing else to say.
Don't take any shit. Go fuck yourselves,
and please don't get a tattoo of a
skull on your body. All right. See you.